[Musica]
è una bellissima occasione per parlare
di una bellissima storia stiamo
raccontando una storia vi racconterò una
storia bella non una storia triste certo
con grandi problematiche ma una storia
bella perché siamo convinti che il bene
genera bene il bene genera bene e tutti
noi siamo chiamati in maniera diversa
essere generatori di bene
la storia inizia all 88 anzi prima
ancora il 18 aprile del 2015
quel giorno purtroppo per l'ennesima
volta vediamo immagini che ancora oggi
vediamo e vediamo vediamo vediamo
vediamo
però certe immagini non solo le vidi le
immagini ti interrogano c'è una
coscienza dentro di noi
questa coscienza me gridava a un certo
punto gridava e quindi sono tornato a
casa dopo l'ennesimo l'ennesima tragedia
quel giorno morirono più di 700 persone
sotto la sua casa e ho lanciato la
cartella proprio arrabbiato e ho detto
ad alta voce non possiamo restare così
indifferenti e chiaro che il peso no di
certi fatti può inibire le persone ma in
quel momento io sentivo il dovere di
lanciare un messaggio di apertura al
mondo piccolo apriamo la nostra casa
apriamo la nostra porta di casa
quando dici queste parole mia moglie che
era in cucina non disse nulla ma quel
silenzio era secondo da tempo era
secondo poi parlai con i miei quattro
figli perché io abbiamo quattro figli e
e la risposta loro fu di grande
entusiasmo
a quel punto parti questa bellissima
avventura questa bellissima avventura
che già trasformato tante volte mi
chiedono quanti soldi ho fatto e io
rispondo sempre si sono miliardario sono
diventato miliardario di umanità un
miliardario di umanità la la cosa più
bella è che quando inizia un'avventura
di questo genere non devi metterti a
fare i conti i calcoli deve aprire il
suo cuore la tua mente sapendo che
l'incontro farà la differenza infatti
dico sempre a tutti venite e vedete
venite e vedete è stato bello pensare
che sono arrivate addirittura
scolaresche da danzica
oppure è venuto il giornalista di al
jazeera per capire e io ho sempre
invitato tutti tutti chiunque ancora
oggi per me è importante venite e vedete
perché nell'incontro con l'altro
l'incontro però non attraverso è
soltanto un filmato non all incontro
personale con l'altro si incrociano gli
occhi degli altri e capisci che hai
davanti una persona una persona come te
che desidera come te di vivere in un
certo modo
io credo che se questo sia è una lezione
che noi abbiamo ricevuto e io continuo a
dire che abbiamo ricevuto e stiamo
ricevendo perché mai sono quattro anni e
mezzo ricevendo molto di più di quello
che abbiamo dato e questo è possibile
ta la cosa è successo è successo che voi
immaginate siamo diventati da sei siamo
diventati 12 perché noi abbiamo accolto
sei profughi provenienti appunto
lassù sarà e quindi invece avere quattro
figli adesso ci ritroviamo con dieci
figli e in questo camminare insieme
la diversità è evidente e non è
soprattutto la diversità della pelle è
la diversità di cultura e l'inter fessi
diversità di modo di guardare il mondo
però insieme
loro sono musulmani noi siamo cristiani
insieme abbiamo costruito una nuova
famiglia dove ognuno si rispetta e io
sono convinto che la dimensione
dell'ospitalità è fondamentale perché
universale e dove però coloro che
vengono accolti devono assolutamente
adattarsi alle situazioni del contesto
quindi cosa è successo
e vengo a questo famoso sei più sei pass
è successo che la nostra casa è
diventato un piccolo laboratorio da
piccolo laboratorio e poi è diventato un
modello un modello di accoglienza
diffusa questo piccolo laboratorio cosa
ha fatto niente
molto semplice era abbiamo dato la
possibilità a questi ragazzi di
recuperare primi tutto le ferite del
corpo e anche le ferite dello spirito e
poi e poi e poi come abbiamo
incominciato a dire signori siamo in
italia
l'italiano è obbligatorio signori siamo
in italia siamo nel veneto il
volontariato è una cosa normale
siate volontari anche voi siamo giovani
tracciamo lo sport tutte queste attività
sono state fatte dai ragazzi e la cosa
bella è che poi dopo queste attività e
sono diventato il modo di comunicare con
gli altri di conoscersi e dopo ciò
abbiamo anche fatto un tirocinio
professionalizzante e un tirocinio
professionalizzante dove la cosa
fondamentale era prima di tutto che se
c'era qualche italiano che avrebbe
voluto avesse voluto fare questo
tirocinio prima gli italiani poi i miei
figli neri così anche se ci fosse stato
un a una persona in maternità o in cassa
integrazione prima gli italiani
e poi i figli neri hanno fatto il
tirocinio e dopo li hanno assunti tutti
ormai sono due anni e mezzo che tutti
lavorano tre di questi hanno anche
addirittura un contratto a tempo
indeterminato e adesso in maniera a
conclusione di tutto questi ragazzi mi
hanno chiesto giustamente papa ma adesso
noi vogliamo uscire fuori da questa casa
e costruire la nostra famiglia non è una
cosa poco capite che qui le cose
cambiano e io ho cercato di dimostrare
una cosa ho immaginato che questa
esperienza potesse essere traslitterata
dentro un comune e così ho immaginato
che ogni 5.000 abitanti ogni comuni
5.000 abitanti non solo in italia ma in
tutta europa accolga un nucleo di sei
persone ogni 10.000 abitanti massimo due
nuclei di sei persone ogni 15.000
abitanti
massimo tre nuclidi sei persone si
ridistribuiamo sui 60 milioni di
italiani e sui 510 milioni di europei
il problema viene rivisto e corretto in
maniera completamente diversa
questo l'ho detto al presidente a
repubblica italiana che non ringrazio
moltissimo nella sua fiducia
l'ho detto davanti a montecitorio l'ho
detto al parlamento europeo ea
strasburgo a bruxelles e anche a
strasburgo e molto in mente lo dirò
all'onu perchè perchè son convinto che
un momento di cambiamento come questo
c'è bisogno di riuscire a a guardare
oltre la collaborazione di tutti
solo insieme possiamo cambiare la terra
dice una ragazza non è tua
sua è nostra ma è vero il mondo e i
nostri un mondo globalizzato che ha
bisogno di tutti in maniera diversa in
modo diverso con molta tranquillità con
molta serenità sei più sei più sei
più sei più sei ma cosa è successo
perché per 6 perché in quel per se ci
sono sei figure che con i fondi che
arrivavano dall'europa e dall'italia
abbiamo assunto ed è la figura del della
psicologa la figura dell'insegnante la
figura dell'operatrice la figura del
medico abbiamo sempre pagato quei soldi
del che arrivavano
tenete presente che poi non esiste una
legislazione che dà la possibilità in
italia di accoglie direttamente dalla
famiglia era soltanto un momento di
grande tragedia nel 2015 le prefetture
avevano invitato tutti ad accogliere e
quindi noi abbiamo dovuto affidarci a
una cooperativa quindi noi non abbiamo
mai ricevuto un soldo direttamente alla
nostra famiglia
gli ho chiesto soltanto per la famiglia
il raddoppio delle bollette
ma la cosa bella è che abbiamo con quei
soldi potuto dare la possibilità a tante
figure professionali italiane doc
d'origine controllata dolci gigi
garantita erano tutti del paese o
trevigiane di fare la loro professione
professionalità molto belle e importanti
come la psicologa dell'operatrice la
mediatrice culturale medico l'avvocato e
pagati regolarmente
allora io ho visto una cosa positiva non
ho visto una cosa negativa e o qui e
sento il dovere di poterlo raccontare
come un raccontato a voi sapendo che
ognuno di noi sa cosa vuol dire aprire
una porta
grazie
[Applauso]